que ne se retrouver chez moi tout seul à
rien faire c'était vraiment dur pour moi
le confinement pèse lourdement sur celle
que l'on appellera joannie pour protéger
son identité
placé en famille d'accueil à l'âge de 8
ans elle s'apprête à 17 ans a quitté le
système de la direction de la protection
de la jeunesse est en pleine pandémie
joigny a décidé de repousser la
poursuite de ses études
j'avais comme hugues dalleau sujet je
voulais devenir policière depuis tout
petit
mais là avec ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est vraiment compliqué donc je
vais peut-être prendre une année
sabbatique
je pense que ça va laisser des traces la
dpj jasick à côté du monde connaît bien
elle a vécu dans vingt familles
d'accueil
aujourd'hui devenu intervenant
psychosocial sept ans je suis parti en
appartement justement avec le tribunal
qui motorisait mon émancipation mais je
pense que ce serait arrivé dans une
crise comme ceux j'aurais peut-être pas
eu le même parcours décrochage problèmes
de santé mentale difficultés d'accès au
logement
elle s'inquiète des effets de la
pandémie sur les adolescents surtout
ceux qui doivent faire la transition
vers la vie adulte
c'est certain que nous on veut laisser
la chance aux jeunes qui sont prêts
qu'ils sont capables de partir mais on
vous si on veut prévenir l'itinérance
plusieurs provinces canadiennes ont
adopté des moratoires sur les sorties
des services sociaux pour éviter que des
jeunes soient forcées de quitter leur
milieu de vie en ces temps de crise mais
pas le québec
déjà seront très rapidement sur le
terrain pour que nos intervenants il
faut voir l'évolution de la pandémie
lionel carmant assure qu'il est
impossible d'exiger de quelqu'un qui
atteint la majorité de demeurer à
l'endroit où il a été placé mais qu'en
aucun temps il ne sera tolérée de
renvoyer aux jeunes à la rue jacques
audrey le ministre délégué à la santé et
aux services sociaux à lionel carmant a
aussi fait le point sur la situation des
signalements et des listes d'attentes à
la dpj
il affirme qu'il n'a aucun enfant sur
les listes d'attentes à la dpj
à laval et dans la majorité des régions
québec à l'exception de l'estrie de la
montérégie et le navet pourquoi selon
lui c'est grâce aux investissements son
gouvernement qui ont été faits des
millions $ notamment après le décès de
la fillette de granby qui ont permis l
embauche de centaines d'intervenants or
pour le syndicat des travailleurs la pps
ya pas de quoi se réjouir parce que
l'indicateur important ici c'est le
nombre de signalements depuis des années
il ne fait qu'augmenter depuis le début
du confinement
selon le syndicat il a baissé de 30% et
ça c'est très inquiétant
merci jacques collet